hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast
flow cytometry data analysis in a flash
I'm Christina jewel of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by Beckman
culture Life Sciences Beckman Coulter is
dedicated to advancing the optimum
optimizing of the laboratory the
company's global leadership and
world-class service and support delivers
sophisticated instrument systems
reagents and services to life science
researches in academic and commercial
laboratories enabling new discoveries in
biology based research and development
for more information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or you can
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button on the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Joyce Slusser
dr. Joyce lesser is a senior scientist
at KCAs bio analytical and biomarker
Services dr. Slusser recently joined
KCAs in 2016
bringing with her the knowledge and
expert
tee's to expand KCAs flow cytometry and
tissue culture offerings her proficiency
in flow cytometry stems from years in
the lab at two medical colleges and as a
consulting scientist in a corporate
setting over the past 20 plus years she
has gained experience across multiple
species and platforms both in research
settings and in clinical settings her
education is rooted in immunology
virology hematology and oncology joyce
has published over 15 articles and is an
active member in the International
Society of analytical psychology
international clinical cytometry society
American Association of immunologists
and founder of Great Plains analytical
cytometry Association I will now turn it
over to dr. Slusser for her presentation
dr. Lutzer
thank you so much for the introduction
and thank you to libraries and Beckman
cultures for facilitating and welcome
all I would like to jump right into the
presentation because I do have an
extensive software demonstration I would
like to do so let's get rolling my first
slide is an introduction to the why KCAs
and how we came to this presentation
today
so first KCAs has been in business for
about 37 years doing pharmacodynamic and
pharmacokinetics study it's a contract
research organization meaning we run
these experiments or studies for our
clients who are by and large
pharmaceutical companies and biosimilars
and biomarkers have recently jumped to
the forefront of pharmacological product
development so things like antibodies
are now being used as drugs which means
we are doing more studies on biomarkers
now than just the drug and its
metabolites so as a contract research
organization we operate in a GLP
environment which is regulated by the
FDA
so DLP means good laboratory practices
these are
very well defined and there are several
publications including a crystal city
guideline which cover how a study should
be conducted and documented
however because biomarker studies are so
new and flow cytometry even newer to the
scene they are not covered specifically
in the Crystal City guidelines so we
apply as many of those guidelines to our
biomarker studies as possible we receive
study samples from across the globe and
one of the things that is critical is
the stability of those biomarkers during
transit over holidays there are always
delays in shipping so one of the first
steps I undertook was to characterize
some of those biomarkers we would be
offering in our portfolio during transit
and stability studies right so I am for
flow cytometry will predominantly
for services on whole blood but also
occasionally bone marrow and CSF and
things like that so peripheral blood
will be collected in a number of ways
but most commonly those are potassium
EDTA sodium heparin ACD and a new player
to the market is a BCP strep tube if
you're not familiar with that is an EDTA
anticoagulant with a fix in the tube all
right so that allows the cell to be
stabilized but it also introduces a new
point of contingency which is that my
antibody must recognize not only fresh
epitopes or fresh markers on the cell
surface but fixed markers in order for
the side-by-side comparison of a fresh
epitope to a fixed epitope and those can
change over time so we set a baseline
for flow cytometry of these biomarkers
at four hours and then we sampled these
again at 24 hours 48 hours 96 hours 144
hours 192 hours and 240 hours but that
it will offer up to 10 days stability on
these biomarkers
all right no one panel will fit
everyone's needs so we have five
different panels that we initiated these
are the dura clone immune monitoring
panels available from Beckman Coulter
the first would be TV MK it offers a
plethora of small sub setting right so
cd45 getting the cd3 you'll see fourth
in case you can pick out NK cells with
256 and the 16 the details with the CD
19 so you can overall get a picture a
snapshot of peripheral blood cells you
will notice that it's a 10 color
instrument I have two open channels
listed that allows my clients choose two
markers that will specifically address
something that they are monitoring then
I have a full pen color panel for teeth
subsets so using cd45 are a CCR 78028
pd-1 etc to characterize further t-cell
subsets or maybe you just need a panel
that looks at t-cell receptors we also
have a b-cell 2 offering ID D and M so
you can know about lineage specificity
of the B cells and then a dendritic cell
so again just to cover the bases we
started with this basic set of markers
so 5 tubes offering a minimum of 8
markers for tube for collection media
and 9 time points so for each donor this
gating on just percent positive versus
negative that's six thousand four
hundred and eighty data points per donor
and we decided to look at three donors
in order to have a full set of
information so I could do some
statistics all right so the girls on my
presentation today are to tell you how
to manipulate that 6500 data points per
donor link gates across study file so
that each file is analyzed in the same
fashion generate report and you just
in a GOP session that allows you to
retain original data and further
subsetted data or reportable data or
statistics however you wish to turn that
to increase the throughput of those
seven seven thousand data points and
maximize output using something called
composites
alright so without any further ado if
you'll give me just a moment I am going
to start sharing my dot my desktop so we
can jump into the software all right
so hopefully you will see a screen in
front of you that has dot plots and
histograms and as I am no longer looking
at the window that gives me feedback I'm
going to assume this is the case all
right so what I've loaded on the left
side are a number of tubes and as I
hover over them you will see that some
of them have thousands of events and
some of them have up to 1 million events
so some of these files are quite large
we're going to start at the top of the
list but just for demonstration purposes
if you are ready to load your dataset
you would click on the little red
collusive all and open files and import
them so my first set of data are going
to be quality control samples for my
flow cytometer and the first of those is
the flow set bead this is a bead of
design fluorescence for me and I have
selected channels in my dot plot that I
target my beads to and these targets
allow me to optimize my voltages on my
PMT's in order to see negative
populations and positive populations
fully contained on my floor log scale
down here and always have my data in the
same place so if I want to manipulate
hundreds of files and have them all
gated similarly I need the populations
not to bump around the plot additionally
if I want to draw any conclusions about
regulation approach
or down-regulation of a marker I need
those populations to remain fixed with
respect to each other and I'll show you
what that means shortly and how I
document that all right so suffice it to
say I look at single beads I have a
defined area or target where those beads
must appear the instrument actually
automatically adjust the voltages to get
those feeds into these channels all
right then I run my single color control
tubes alright so there are ten of those
plus and autofluorescence too so just
really quickly I'm going to grab a
couple of files and show you what that
looks like
so as the software opens that it will
present a window that says what do you
want to do with all of these tubes I can
click on a single tube and analyze it
individually or I can do some other
actions so today's action is add
selected to a new compensation alright
and if I would choose that the
instrument will or the instrument the
software will look at the data and say
okay you have this mini tube I need you
to tell me is just f l1 f l2 FL 3 FL 4
so if I would click this some of these
are not single color controls where it's
able it will assign a channel these two
is not going to be able to assign for
sure but it finds this one in the
correct channel and this one in the
correct channel so that's all good then
I have three choices here for the method
of doing compensation the first is
positives only if you use CD 45 or CD 4
and you use it in every flavor then
you'll only have positive cells and no
negative cells to gate on
so CD 25 would be a positive only if you
have a population of cells that have
high autofluorescence you may want to do
an auto fluorescent subtraction and you
have that choice for me none of my
markers are expressed globally so I will
always have a positive and a negative
population in my class so I
choose the positive negative and then
you click generate compensation right so
if you think about what compensation
looks like for a four-color instrument
this is where I started it the 50
channel versus the PE channel the 50
channel versus the ECD channel and the
50 channel versus the PT size 5 channel
for instance that's not too difficult of
a compensation to set up when you have
10 colors in a tube this is a 10 color
panel I now have instead of I instead of
those few plus a 10 color panel has 56
cots to evaluate for compensation that's
a lot of tweaking so I always start with
my auto compensation using the software
to get global settings that I can apply
and tweak if necessary all right so this
regardless of what order they're listed
across the bottom of my screen you'll
see that they're listed in the order of
the FL channel so I'm going to close
this tab to the left so we have more
real estate here alright 50 is along the
bottom of each of these plots so
everything is plotted against the 50
channel and the next thing I'm going to
show you is by clicking on one of these
boxes I can globally adjust this gate
across all of the 50 ductless so here
are where my negatives are on all of
those dot plots and I can grab this one
and address these are all linked gates
the gate around the positives alright so
once I adjust my gate
I have negative and positive now the
software is going to look at the mean of
this population actually the median the
median of this population on the Y
versus a median of this population on
the Y and so you can see those are very
dissimilar and compensation will be
required I have one weird little box
down here so if you'll remember my bead
not every channel has a target right in
the middle of
the PMT some for flora Chrome's are
extremely bright some fluorochromes are
extremely dim so if I use the same
settings for a really bright for Chrome
as a really dim for Chrome for the gym
for Chrome my negatives will be below
zero and my positives will be somewhere
in the middle for the really bright for
Chrome my negatives will be too high and
mine it by positives maybe off scale so
each of these is optimized for the floor
chrome being used and some of the
targets are quite low so let's go back
to this compensation so that's first
less you're here well the 50 is the same
across the bottom of the plot you will
notice on the Y that the populations are
not in the same place so these are kind
of high because Chrome orange is kind of
dim these are kind of high because at
glue with kind of dim they're both
excited by the 405 these are smashed up
against the axis I've extended this one
in something called logical so if I get
here I have a what the users are called
by exponential and other users would
call illogical I can plot below zero
what those populations would look like
these dates are no longer linked but
it's if I return them to where they
should be with logarithmic they are now
linked all right
so for really bright for Chrome negative
can be really negative for really dim
for crumbs negative can be fairly bright
it's just part of using all of these
different floor Chrome's together and
making them play nicely so I will have a
tab then for all of the for Chrome that
I'm utilizing so in this case FL to PE
is across all of my x-axis against my
wife and a cop
datian matrix will be generated based on
the calculation to require to bring
these medians for the populations
together okay so running a ten color
experiment and all of those dot plot
thirty fifty fifty six dot plots that's
a lot of data and if you had a sub
population that you wanted to draw a box
around and say this is my stop
every time the instrument runs a sample
at the end of that sample it will spend
time putting all of those dots where
they're supposed to be and updating all
of those statistics at the end of the
run and you can't go on to the next
sample until that's done so the data
processing bit during acquisition can
really slow down your acquisition that's
not my goal I want to acquire two
samples as quickly as I can once they
are stained and ready to go and then do
my analysis offline so using my post
updates to set my targets using my
single color controls to generate my
compensation matrix I can jump right
into my first sample as soon as those
are accomplished and I don't need
they're going to be nor do I need very
many of these single color controls so
my first sample that I run I'll have a
few dates and mostly histograms and
maybe an informational plot just so I
can keep track all right not a lot of
boxes to populate before I move on to
the next sample but all the information
I need to be in order to know if this
sample was prepared properly lights
properly and is running correctly all of
our data is collected uncompensated
because that's another process that the
instrument must do while it's running
and acquiring that I don't need it to be
doing so my data is collected unguided
and uncompensated so I've generated a
compensation matrix here I'll go to the
Kaluza bottle and I'll say save selected
add and choose compensation and give it
a name when I arrive at my first data
set I can apply that compensation or I
can apply it across
every date a bit in the set right and
these histograms are not very
informative so I am going to create the
template of reporting that I want with
although the correct gate and I'm going
to add that and so I do that by just
adding a new sheet and on this new sheet
I can save anything that was useful from
the first page well I can copy and now I
have two choices for pasting paste and
paste as a link if I paste this is this
sheet is independent of the other sheet
if I paste as a link what you'll see is
this little chain link in the corner of
the box and it means that when I move
something on this dot plot it's also
changed on my original so it's a way of
linking together gates across pages
alright so I will create a report sheet
that gives me a down-and-dirty
something that maybe the client needs to
know how the samples were they proceed
with the next collection on that
particular individual so I create those
templates and here is one this is an
empty template and it says drop data set
here you can't read that part so I have
two options I can drag my data set into
an empty protocol and populate it so now
I have multiple sheets and I have dots
in the box or I can take the data the
protocol I'm sorry take the protocol and
drag it on to a data set that I just
collected and now it's no longer a
single imported tab but my reporting
caps as well alright looking at this
reporting tab is my first opportunity to
look at my compensation so this isn't
uncompensated how do I know that one the
compensation matrix is all 0 to my cd4
should not be up in a box where my CVS
are these should be independent
they should not be Co staining in a
single individual a human so now I'm
going to import the compensation that I
just paid with my compensation matrix
and each cells will now go into the box
where they're supposed to be and my
compensation matrix is populated so I
use my single color control to generate
a compensation matrix which I applied to
my sample okay
Dalton protocol for recording all the
data bits that I want to it has you know
who ran it where it was run and some
statistics and I have something that I
can quickly export to a PDF print
selected and I'll say my current sheet
this report as a PDF and I can drop that
into a box for my client to look at
comment on Cheney movie gate and we can
quickly update any statistics if they
have questions I can add gossage pretty
easily now I have multiple data sets
over multiple times on multiple foods
how do you hand me that okay so scroll
down just a little bit all of these data
sets are just the EDTA collection over a
period of time my poor hour my 24-hour
my 48-hour $96.00 116 hours 192 hours 24
yards that's just the EDTA on an
individual number one how do I put
together and make any conclusion
and make a report or I create a new
sheet and have my phenotyping to have be
a report of all of the statistics
associative my hip
right because over time you don't expect
that this populations will stay in
perfectly so I just created a few
examples here and I will show you how I
did that
so on this toolbar here is something
called an information plot you click on
that and you get a little table that
allows you to scroll through your FGS
header and pull out list of information
the title of the study when it was run
who ran it a sinner
the times date then I can go to my data
set and choose any gate and any
statistics collected so the number of
events the percent in that gate the
total mean TV standard deviation yes all
right so I have a gate it has some
events in it I know the fluorescence on
those events so this is the the median
of the cd14 negatives in the FL 5
channel which is cd14 this is a median
for the cd14 positive in the same
channel so if I want to know how intense
the signal is over the background the
negative population I create this is an
Excel spreadsheet I create an equation
and that equation is the median of the
cd4 teens on this on the FL 5 parameter
divided by the median of the negative in
the same parameter so for data review
someone with a calculator can say 5.0 6
divided by 0.25 is 19.9 3 and know that
the calculation is correct but I don't
have to do it and when I run the next
tube I can apply the same data sheet to
that file so TV for signal is signal to
noise is 19.9 3 at 4 hours in AEDPA at
24 hours the signal to noise is 11.8 7
for the same signal can you see that
visually yes is a percentage change
not significantly from three from 4:30
to three
my theory is a dimming of the marker on
the circuit at 48 hours that signal is
1509 still not substantially reduced in
number but starting to go away now I've
nearly lost the cd14 positive population
even though those it's those that are
still there have a distinguishable
signal so I have doubled the data set
from 6480 points data points to twelve
thousand nine hundred and sixty data
points because not only am i reporting
the percent positive but i'm also
reporting the signal-to-noise ratio for
the markers for each of them others in
that tube so you can start to see that
the data analysis and the data points
generated gets a little bit out of hand
when you do this for a number of samples
and all of this data have to be exported
to excel for comparison right no and it
should have you out so this is that data
set you'll see that this is a four hour
this is a 24 or this is a 48 hour and
the 96 etc so the nine time points in
the EDTA for the first donor for the t
v-- NK panel and I've done something
called composite so instead of being
able to click on each file individually
and view it what I have is a list of
files and some foxes are selected and
again just like the single color
controls all of the tubes are listed
across the bottom of the page because
I'm a report sheet so it can go visit
them individually and look at the
information just as it appeared on my
individual file but then I can click
over to my composite and look at each
data set which is linked to the original
and look at the gates and the data
together so here's the for our closest
here's the
our dataset look how pretty those
monocytes are out there at four hours
they still look pretty at 24 hours they
still look pretty they're a few more of
them and they're starting to trail off
by 48 hours virtually 50% reduction in
signal and 50% reduction remember
positive losing them gone
so EDTA is not the happiest place for
monocytes to hang out after a couple of
days so you wouldn't want to do a
monocyte study in a BGA collection
because within 4 days all of your signal
is gone alright now I have all of these
data sets together I have an Excel
spreadsheet associated with this data
set I can also now do things like
compare data and gates across the data
set so I click on the comparison plot
and it brings me this box if I make it a
little bigger it'll get its own space on
the plushy so here's my data set 9 data
points I want to measure the mean of the
population and the station of the
population the percent data disorder -
let's just choose this move it
you
you
hi everyone it appears we are
experiencing a little bit of patient
seems I was disconnected I hope you can
hear me now I'm going to jump back to
the screen
just to make sure clean raw audio and it
looks like we're back alright so what I
did was choose a number of events to
plot against very escape so this is a
befell the cd19 positives across two
subsets I can add the cd4 cd25 across
the subsets I can do this as a graph but
I can also do this as well got thrown
off my game there has a bar chart right
I like my bar charts rather than graphs
but it's up to each individual user all
right so what I did in my first table is
group to those TBN caves and how long
they persist in EDTA in my second the
monocyte and my third I'm looking at
class two on each of my subpopulations
and how long it per says what percent of
the population stays positive right this
is the one we just created right so let
me jump back to the analysis list and
the first step that we're looking at is
the EDTA
so now this is the heparin
what do those subpopulations look like
well let's have a look I find this to be
the fastest way I can create the
template once and then drag and drop
data into my template so this one is 360
hours 1-4 if you read through that label
I can drag it into this box
now if I scroll back up you'll see that
one of these things is not like the
others this is a 360 our time point of 1
- 4 where this is a 24-hour time point
of 1 - 1
this is donor 1 ETA this is donor 1 BCG
- right so moist the template is built I
can drag and drop data this is going to
sieve my analysis on the backend for
reporting so in a GOP environment you do
the first phase method development where
you tweak all of your reagents and you
tweak all of your settings and you tweak
all of your templates and once
everything is where you need it to do we
lock it down to see this is - their
system for testing hey so now I have a
template I do my sample testing a drag
and drop my data into my templates and
I'm on a roll so I kind of sidetracked
myself there by showing you how to use
popular that's exactly what I did
moving on to the next slide
all right so real quickly to recap we
covered generating a template labeling
of data file
zooming we did not cover zooming into
data we did cover a resolution of data
we can go back and cover Jimmy linking
datasets ie creating a composite linking
gates across the datasets in those
composites using the information tool to
create the statistics at the bottom and
generating an Excel spreadsheet creating
data tables and graphs using Kaluza
creating reports and then exporting data
to excel so I see that we missed
covering exporting data to excel so I'm
going to go through the software alright
so I have this really pretty table and I
have all of this data can I export it to
excel and the answer is yes
actually I'm going to go up to the top
of the page
so I have this summary table with
calculations I also this is known as a
hierarchical gate so I have the
relationship between these populations
described in boolean gating here I'm
going to click on the red ball and I'm
going to say export and now I can do
selected statistics this statistics from
this current sheet any report sheet all
of the sheets or multiple sheets so this
will take me to a CSV sheet right so CSV
outputs and I can save the data from
this file so that's exporting statistics
the other thing I didn't cover was to
zoo tool so let me find here's a dot
plot and we want to know more about
these cells at the bottom so I'm going
to click on the zoom
relatively big file and you're able to
doesn't like all my videos open to zoom
in on populations of so now it's going
to do it right so it's changed how my
picture is displayed and I've zoomed in
on a subpopulation of cells okay so
there's a zoom in and a zoom out tool
trying to double clicked so that you can
go in and look at subpopulations of
interests that's important if you're
doing things like tempo and there's
0.01% of the sub population right you
will maybe help you to draw a better
gait
if you can zoom in and click around a
subpopulation that you want okay
we'll go back to the presentation right
so creating reports zooming linking
exporting to excel all right so now I
made some tables for you I have an
extremely large data set and some of
these files have over a million events
getting through all of them for all
three donors was going to be extremely
difficult so we just zoomed in on the TV
NK which is quite useful to most people
and then we created this summary slide
for this presentation so the donor
number one collected in ETA across these
nine time points we were able to draw
some conclusions by sub population
percentages so overall integrity was
about 48 hours I start to lose my entire
lymph distribution so percent positive
deviate substantially after 144 hours so
we can look at individual markers or
subpopulations and draw conclusions so
EDTA you need to get it into the
laboratory and look within 48 hours to
96 hours if you really want to know
anything about the population if you use
heparin probably won't surprise you that
this sample is stable for a little bit
longer than in EDTA right so macrophages
and monocytes especially don't like EDTA
but they're a little bit happier in
heparin and the populations are
stabilized for a little bit longer
some of the samples are some of the
markers don't look good after 26 but
overall you can go from maybe four or
five days
if you collect in the BCT tube that's
the tube with EGA and fix most of those
markers last well into the weekend right
and the distribution is pretty clear out
to 360 hours I didn't display all that
data past 240 but the tube hangs in
there except for the KT 25 pretty long
alright so collecting with a fix in the
tube if you're just doing t-cell
monitoring or b-cell monitoring you
aren't good right if you collect an ACD
then you're also going to last for a
substantial amount of time right most of
the distribution anyway looks good close
to 360 hours so if I was going to do
something where I needed to do a
stimulation etc in order to collect
cytokines or information about signaling
or treatment in a petri dish in the
laboratory I would want an ACD tube if
I'm going to do a study and just report
out surface or intracellular markers I'm
probably going to go with a BCP tube and
because it's fixed and I actually
receive samples that were frozen
accidentally and because they had been
fixed the epitopes were still pretty
good and the sample looked pretty good
so I'm going to report on mine in my GOP
fashion that the samples were not stored
appropriately during storage and
shipment but that the markers did look
pretty good when I received the samples
all right so my conclusions I'm going to
wrap this up the toolbars included as
you saw I could do things like get the
wheel with all of the tools that's a
simple right click on any clot or box
they're easy to access they're pretty
intuitive I was pretty impressed with
the software development team they sit
you in front of the computer they open
up the software and then they give you
at little tasks to do and they put a
little camera on the laptop and they
watch how you search
the screen for things and where you
expect them to be and the next time you
go in to beta test the software those
tools are right where you went to look
in the first place
so I have to say it was the funnest
software development experience that
I've ever had and I was really impressed
each time I went back to try the
software that the tweaks have been made
so it's quite intuitive and
straightforward to use and makes me
happy I look for cytometry and this
software makes me very happy
we covered creating templates and using
them in a reproducible fashion for
analysis we talked about manipulating
large data files and data sets so
regardless of how many statistics I pile
onto this thing the templates open up -
they repopulate
I love the gate and updates my
statistics it I have a profound ability
to crash software and break things and
it's tough for me was colluded to find a
way to break it I've done it once or
twice but they take trouble shot right
through it alright so we looked at
merging files making composites linking
gate datasets linking gates in order to
standardize your workflow and your data
reporting and then we talked about
incorporation of tables into the report
format to allow for quick reprocessing
but also a straightforward data review
there's no look at Excel
and then look at the plot sheet to see
that the numbers match look at the Excel
and then look at the plot sheet to make
sure the numbers match and then look at
the calculation because it's all on the
page and in three pages of PDF you can
straight forward review follow these
markers and statistics alright so I
really would like to thank you for
participating today it's been an awesome
experience for me to give this
presentation and I will let Christy my
moderator read some questions thank you
doctor
Plus err for that informative
presentation now before we do get
started on the Q&A session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
those questions you can submit questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can okay
dr. Slusser our first question is does
your machine do auto voltage based on
the beads or do you make the adjustments
manually I can do either it is a Beckman
Coulter novios 10 color instrument with
3 layers so I can use beads to acquire
settings or if I'm just setting
something up for the first time with
development I use my antibodies to tell
the story and then I tell the beads
where I want them to be and then I used
to be to standardize the data sets so it
can go either way
how do you add text and graphics to the
report sheets Oh so I skipped that and I
won't exit because it takes time but
there is a cute little icon that's
called text box and you can open the
text box and for instance I can import
the KCAs logo and put it on all of my
data sheets you can also type in a box I
have created for other users places
where they can write comments etc or
sign into proofing
textbook is it possible to see an
example of autofluorescence subtraction
I do not have any but I am sure there is
someone at Beckman Coulter who has run
something that is ugly that could give
you a demo if you're in an institution
with a flow cytometry cord they can
probably get you samples and I should
mention Kaluza will open just about
anything that you collected so it
doesn't matter what instrument you
collected it on if it's in the LM d FCS
format it can be opened and analyzed
are the numbers in percentages or MFI
however you choose so you can do median
you can do arithmetic mean you can do
geometric mean that was one of my jokes
I was going to tell it to beginning the
presentation right I'm in Shawnee Kansas
which is in the arithmetic and geometric
mean of the North America if you
consider how many people are on each
coast
it's not a very good for cytometry joke
but there you have it
can you explain also if it's possible
ApS diagram how you don't know what that
is
we could probably answer this offline if
we get the answer to that yeah
yes our audience member can submit a
more specific question be more elaborate
on that yes doctor sir what would the
stability of cd34 cells be and the
different types of additives and the
collection tubes
I think cd34 is pretty stable and would
be BCT fixable again it's more about the
antibody that you choose recognizing a
fixed epitope so we were pretty careful
in our selection of antibodies for
recognizing the fresh and fixed epitope
so that we could get the same answer
across datasets but I'd be more than
happy to give it a try if someone wants
to send me some information
how to how would you get the percentage
of bullion gate the same way you get
percentage of any other games so it will
do over a percentage of parents right is
what's going to be reported on the
statistics bar so if it's leukocytes and
lymphocytes and CD three and CD four it
will be of the parent is there any
specific voltage value for each cell
line or does it depend just on the
analysis protocol of search cell markers
so settings will be different for doing
apoptosis than from doing surface
markers and from doing intracellular
because you've done different things to
the cell so I would say no one set of
settings fits everything but you can
create some generalized settings that
work for most things okay doctor so so
we have a question that came in says
automatic separator populations I
believe they're asking been but I if
that's Auto gating
I'm going to let Beckman Coulter take
that question
there was a really handy tool that
they've just created that you one click
and you get positive and negatives on a
histogram there are auto gating tools in
the software for acquisition the
compensation matrix comes up with an
auto gate but I don't know that there's
auto gating in collusive specifically so
I will let Beckman Coulter follow up on
that question because I'm not really
sure
very good let's see we have so many
great questions coming in I saw one that
says is it single user or multiple user
and the answer is yes there are both so
you can get a single license for a
single individual you can get a network
license for your institution the
institution comes with a number of seats
first in first
you know occupies the seat so you log in
you log out and you always have extra
seats available for people to use hello
it looks like that color is going to
reply to the APS question oh yes you
this is Laura Pejic I am the product
manager for Kaluza and a couple comments
Kaluza at this point does not have auto
gating it is on our roadmap for future
build to follow up with respect to the
question that Joyce has talked about
with Kaluza versions there are multiple
formats of collusive that are available
they range from a single user one-year
license or a perpetual license up to
multi user network licenses that Joyce
described and each of these are priced
at either commercial or for academic
institutions
very good Thank You Laura for clarifying
that
and I believe that we are out of time
for any more questions but we'd love to
open up dr. slicer for any final
comments that you have for our audience
I have used a lot of software in 30
years and been through a number of
revisions of software's out there
I was a dyed-in-the-wool true fan of
several other versions until I met
Kaluga and I have to say I fell in love
with even the first version which was
pretty clunky but as I said they were
very responsive to needs wants and
desires for the software and I felt a
little bit more in love with it each
time it comes out so and the stands true
for instrumentation I have run a lot of
instrumentation over the years and the
fact that there's one software there
will open many many different versions
of a file and I can set gates on my data
collected on my Acura and turn around
and save that protocol and apply it to a
different instrument like just put that
protocol on to data from a different
instrument and how the gates in the same
place makes me very happy
it's it's extremely flexible so that
would be my parting shot
thank you again dr. Joyce lesser I would
also like to thank our sponsor Beckman
Coulter for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 9th 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you next time
goodbye